some of my favorite things to do on a
Saturday is to read thirst tweets with
anthony mackie so let's see what a
thirst tweet says Thursday I want
someone to look at me the way Sebastian
and Anthony Mack you look at each other
oh that's great that's great nice
anthony mackie you cutie pie
come sit on my face I will eat your s
like a fudge brownie first of all yeah
send a ticket to let's do this that was
sweet a fudge brownie I don't know what
this means
Sebastian says one thick BiH right yeah
that's kind
Anthony Maggie's ass is the real
America's ass I concur thank you
I heard Evan saying that no no no no no
I work I work a lot to to keep the
bountiful nature of the round brown
alive so enjoy it okay so listen when
anthony mackie said those steel blue
eyes let you know where home is it's my
safe about Sebastian's eyes which I felt
that thank you very kind how do you feel
about that don't look at me man don't
look me in the eyes look over here when
you talk to me give them the money feel
I feel that I figure that's good
thinking about Anthony Mackie taking a
nap on Sebastian's couch don't bother me
you have a nice couch you you have a
nice homey
never see what's the best thing in your
house never been in my house that's a
lot all right fine you see other people
breaking in because of your couch all
right fine it's an awful couch Sebastian
split me in half like a pistachio send
tweet send tweet is that like me to like
respond to the thing thank God I don't
have Twitter and this is why because you
don't like pistachios no I love
pistachio Oh cashews are my favorite
though Anthony Mackie is so fine I hope
his Cheetos are flaming hot like him
they are you know what
they are and them flaming hot Funyuns is
the jail anthony mackie as captain
america makes me horny like put that
shield against my neck as uh as a lie
it's a lot it's a good ride thank you
for allowing me to make you horny good
night and good luck
[Music]